Hi! Welcome to Starbucks.
This is Olivia and Janice.
Can I interest you in trying a Spiced Chai Mocha?
I need a Caramel Macchiato, so make it a grande;...
...a double shot espresso, extra whip on a latte;...
...a Tazo Passion or Green Shaken Iced Tea;...
...and while you're at it, heat up a muffin for me.
I wanna Peppermint White Chocolate soy milk Mocha;...
...don't make it too hot, 'cause I don't wanna choke - a.
I want something else, wait a second or three.
Yeah, a Pumpkin Spice Frap light blended coffee.
I wanna triple grande cinnamon latte with soy,...
...and a copy of Sheff's book, "Beautiful Boy".
Give me something now, I want something to eat...
...'cause a Seven Layer Bar is my favorite treat.
I want a Cream Cheese Danish and a hot cross bun...
...and then a poppy seed bagel, just for fun.
Now that I have plenty of food, I got one more order so make it good:...
...a tall caramel frap with caramel on top,...
...'cause I'm flat like two napkins, won't spill a drop.
Don't worry 'bout payment 'cause I got a gift card,...
...hope this complicated order isn't too hard.
But I really do hope I get my order for free...
...'cause if not, you all gotta spit a rap back at me.